ça va commencer tpr est encore sous la
douche froide les gars soda avec pai
géante salut toi il est peut-être temps
qu'on fasse à nouveau film holiday et
scobee mais faut d'abord faire une bande
annonce beaucoup tu peux faire la voix
off de la bande annonce dans un monde
dévasté par les forces du mal à
[Musique]
découvrir l'extraordinaire essayer d
origine de la plus grande équipe de
héros
toute l'histoire
mystère et amada serré
[Musique]
oui
et vu ce chien héros doit venir avec moi
c'est pas un chat errant
ouais comment il s'appelle qui s'appelle
ce quiz deuxième prénom double nom de
famille
[Musique]
d'aviva france je ne l'enlèverai jamais
avoué east perf et je me sens moi c'est
près de boissy verhaeren et elle c'est
daphné son nom et ses amis et voici
scooby doo
salut à tous
oui
il
oh sammy et scooby ont été enlevés est
ce que tu te raconte t on à une envolée
sur mon vieux un style moderniste et
exemble apaisante déclinée sur plusieurs
tons rose fuschia projeté dans le cd tu
as dit si j'étais dans le futur je dis
que tout ceci va peut-être nous conduire
à sammy et scooby il ya des traces
d'après rasage et de whisky de 12 ans
d'âge a alors ça mon père le méchant de
l'histoire